do you want no it's Nadia true every
dijo miss me lad hamdulillah she's real
to you welcome to another episode of the
Dean show we're here trying to help you
understand Islam and Muslims and today
we have a very very important topic
we're going to be talking about the
verbatim word of God Almighty Allah the
Quran we know that every messenger that
God Almighty sent he sent with
revelation he sent with scripture just
to name a few Moses he came with the
Torah Abraham he came with the scripture
jesus peace be upon him he came with the
NGO the gospel not the Gospels and the
last and final messenger sent to man
kind of Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him he came with the car and this is the
verbatim word of God but how do we know
because the previous scriptures they
were changed altered edited by man how
do we know that this book we have is
indeed unchanged unaltered unedited that
it is indeed the verbatim word of God
we're going to be talking about the
compilation how it came that he just
fall down from the heavens how was it
revealed over a span of 23 years and my
next guest dr. Mohamed mcdo who is the
former professor from the John Hopkins
University he's going to help us tackle
this topic and we come back on the Dean
so we'll be right back love there's only
one
Muhammad is His Messenger a la la la
o Allah there's only one bed Jesus was
his messenger Allah no I did that maybe
it maybe it's just to break the ice I
salamo alaikum peace be unto you dr.
sell em on hopefully America how are you
doing 500 thank God a god you're good
I'm good we're all good hamdullah I'm
very happy to hear that I'm a very as
well it seems like we're the I mean look
I don't need to boast or anything but it
seems like the Muslims are the most
happiest people they're always like
thank god yes the most how you doing pal
hung dude he just says thank God thank
God thank God we do that oh that's
amazing no design is better than
thanking God that's it another side of
the many we just wanted to be godly
people and early and you know what this
book this car and yes well we're talking
about today yeah we want to know how it
was compiled because this is an
instruction manual okay that is for the
whole of mankind so many people are not
in with some audience you know they've
heard this word there's a lot of
misconceptions so how can we give them
this assurance that this is indeed
revelation from the one who created us
talk a little bit about this book Tucker
and the beginning stages and we'll go
from them in a pick your brain I'm just
so excited talk to us shake a little bit
is very little celebrate on this year
because it's an important issue and we
need every human being on the earth to
know how this Quran came to us well
protected will preserve nothing changed
it in it and when you look at it from
many perspective one perspective if you
look at it and if you trust God's words
when he said that in the Quran itself
indeed I sent down the whole Quran and
indeed I will keep it unchanged this
first of all if we if a person believes
that this is the word of God and he
would find this word so it absolutely
would believe that it is that's a stamp
that's not I got this is I got updated
its certified God is certified
absolutely no no no no burrito Muhammad
is the receiver of that's
yeah that's just like Jesus Moses Evelyn
all of them are sailors gosh I'm here
would really i'd like to 11 and the
other one is that I will prove it
exactly as it happened i'll explain the
steps and i leave everybody to think of
how authentic this issue is we muslims
believe that step by step there is
nothing that you can find any gap that
any person in the earth that can prove
that there is a change that happened and
in fact almighty allah himself in the
quran said that had it been from any
other source accept almighty allah
people would have plenty of
discrepancies and contradictions in it
and this is not the case yeah there's
not a single contradiction and I'm quite
sure that if any single contradiction
had been proved Muslims would quit the
Quran be finished up one morning I
wasn't one absolute every child every
old man or a woman every young person
everyone believes that this is from God
not only that still the Quran itself
made a challenge to people and it's not
blunt when I blondie we have evidence
the Quran itself says that if you can do
something similar to it go ahead and
choose so talk to us talk to us now
because when we say the Quran was
revealed that it just fall out of this
heaven of course out of this work course
no tell us it didn't officially it
didn't fall from heaven at all this
story is first of all the first step i
want you i will tell you the name of the
steps first of all the quran was with
almighty allah in something called the
preserver tablets this is a tablet
elohel muffled as allah so allah said in
the Quran Bell who occur on and majeed
gleau him my fault indeed it is a
glorious quran that it is preserved in
the preserve at a blood what does this
preserve a tablet i give just very quick
and it's a tablet that has all the
history of humanity everything in this
universe that happened or will happen
it's already there everything is
since the creation of the tent when
Allah created it and commanded it to
write and it dropped everything that
will happen in this universe until the
day this is called the preserver tablet
LOL muffled the quran was there and it
was in a place called vitalizer bait
Eliza the house of power or the place of
power this is how accurate the Muslims
would know even when it was with
Almighty Allah spinal tap so the
preserver tablets in a place called bait
Eliza now then it was sent down to ya
the lower heaven mmhmm yeah as a whole
yeah the Quran then which tells you a
message here that Almighty Allah noon
very well everything that will happen to
the universe so it came down to the
lowest level of of heaven which is
called yes 8 Eliza this place is
vitalizer so from a low hell my fault
preserved them to bait Eliza the house
of power and it remained there until
yeah and the verse that says that in and
Zell now feel a little cut this process
or this step took place in the Night of
Power which is usually the 27th of the
month of Ramadan the Quran came as a
whole to the lowest heaven to the lowest
sky and it remained there and from there
when Muhammad peace be upon him became a
Messenger of Allah gibril used to
whenever gibril commanded by Almighty
Allah to take this verse by memorization
so gibril with memorize diverse and we
teach this verse to Prophet Muhammad
Saleh sauna so the Quran came in
installments across 23 years whenever an
event an incident something happens The
Lost Planet Allah commands gibril to
come up with the verse or the verses
that address this issue and it was sent
to free muhammad peace be upon
by the same angel is the same a surgery
is absolutely all right the same engine
gave the message to Moses the same angel
who give the message to Abraham the same
message that the same messenger with the
same angel Gabriel who give the message
to Jesus alehissalaam ok he is the same
one same is very different all right and
here's one one thing that a person may
think of gibril may have perhaps made a
mistake and this is when you know the
whole religion when you know that Allah
created angels who do not make mistakes
the default of an angel he doesn't make
mistake not like humans we are humans we
make mistakes but angels don't do this
the angels don't make mistakes absolute
we're going to take a break and we'll be
back on addition we'll be right back no
speech is better than to do that was
call people to Allah and to do there
were no speeches better no nothing is
better than that is it true that if one
person I'm the Allah giving you an
ability to guide someone for the lost
permission the craters permission that
was better than everything in this world
but in the whole world and everything
that's in it in another narration it's
better than the best of wealth but if we
really felt that Eddie would we not be
giving out giving down and this is
something that we encourage all the MSAs
all the dowel organizations the mustards
forget this we want to print more we
give these to the non mrs. for free for
free for free we want our brothers it
we're back we left off where the
Archangel Gabriel Gabriel he is the one
who is sending giving the the
instructions the revelation to the
Prophet Muhammad peace yes absolutely
and yes as I said that this process took
23 years perhaps and the angel would
come to Mohammed salah salem this day
and would give her teach him some verses
two or three or five lines according to
the situation and perhaps after three
months or after three days or after 20
days or after a day or so would come
with another revelation silence now so
we guaranteed it is guaranteed that it
is from Almighty Allah the message came
to Jibril one hundred percent correct
and from Gabriel to Muhammad peace be
upon him it's one hundred percent
correct and from Muhammad peace be upon
him to human beings to the companions
and to the other people one hundred
percent correct now we are talking about
those human beings the Companions of the
prophets and the followers and us how
did they keep the Quran without change
now as I said that gibril would come to
the prophet salah salem and teach him
one or two or three or four verses from
the Quran and the way he taught him like
anyone who teaches in a human being he
would say the verse Muhammad would
repeat the verse and he would review it
one two three times until ya muhammad
sallallahu sell him would learn these
verses there by listening by listening
like exactly how children learn nowadays
they listen to a song they listen to a
prime and they memorize it yes because
of the repetition yeah so this process
continued with the prophet muhammad
sallallahu cellar until some where in
the middle of the message almost a la
spina wa'ta'ala has sit in the quran a
mohamed salah salem
in Nollan yamaha occur on either Cara
inevitably occur on two main nahi bana
what lost planet Alice saying this
version that is a Muhammad don't bother
we are going to guarantee that to ensure
that once you listen to the verse you're
going to mother divine intervention
divine intervention first of all it was
human effort yeah and the wisdom behind
that it shows us how to learn the Quran
how to teach it to other and how to
memorize it by yourself yeah so it's a
human act to tell us how to teach each
other the Quran and this is how all the
people who teach the Quran they use the
same methodology that had been used by
jaibriol with Muhammad peace be upon him
now there's a divine intervention
guaranteeing that every word mohamed
salah salem would hear he would memorize
it it's not a human effort it's a divine
effort yeah what happens when Muhammad
peace be upon him receives few I add few
verses for your lines from the Quran
after he memorizes them he would
immediately teach them to the companion
and this process was continuing in the
life of the prophets lawless and
whenever he received a message he would
memorize it and he would teach it to and
people used to do two things to
memorized by repetition by listening
from the prophets ellis island and the
prophets allah salam used to review this
and he would ask them go ahead and say
it and he would correct them until they
memorize it many of the companions and
he selected for people they are called
for scribes the people who get a battle
why the writers of the revelation his
time on your nice time well he's a lot
of honey in his house not a hundred
years later and heard the same a while
he was alive and in his house because
what I'm saying I'm stressing in his
house because there are many other
people outside they used to write the
Quran by themselves yeah yeah but this
process is taking place in the house of
the prophets allah allah and he himself
was checking
the authenticity of their writing yeah
of course here is an issue if the
Prophet sallallahu is selling they
didn't know how to read or write then we
know that muslims know that the prophets
allah salaam that's confirmed and
illiterate I'd confirm it a la sprout
Allah said in the Quran yes non-biased
historians and also confirmed it so this
is liar okay absolutely yeah yeah if he
knows how to write he would attribute
the Quran to himself never do that yeah
anyway here so the Prophet sallallahu is
hella would after he teaches those four
people and they start writing and those
four people's every Muslim almost know
them by heart it's zaid even a hat and
this is a very big name famous that is
from those caterpillar I leave now we
call it the castle the cousin of the
prophet sallallahu salem obey allah cab
and a cream in abuja those are the four
people are used to write the Quran in
the house of the prophets allah azza
whenever the revelation come to the
prophets allah salam he learns it and he
sends for them he calls them they come
and he asked them to right now for
people are writing not one copy each one
of them is writing his own copy yeah so
now this as i did my heart is writing
and then Alec narita live is writing and
then I carry magneri gel is writing and
then availably cap is rising the four of
them are writing at the same then when
they finish writing the prophets allah
allah allah would recite again and we'd
ask them to review what they have
written because the professor didn't
know how to read so he would ask them to
review what they have written and he
would recite again and according to his
visitation they guarantee you they
ensure that this matches what the
Prophet salasa so now you should
understand that there are two processes
are parallel to each other one is the
oral repetition from which a lot of
people memorize the Quran and the other
time the other thing is that the writing
of the I'd like to elaborate to tell
people hey there audience at the viewers
that of course
the writing at that time it did it's not
it's not similar to the writing that we
have now and if a person knows Arabic
yeah he would know what I mean for
example the most of the writing of
Arabic language in all the newspapers in
all other countries you will find that
it's not written with the vowel system
this is in the nature of our reclaim you
can write the lay the word with the vel
or without the valve you know they let
me give you an example in English if I
apply this to English yes we'd write the
word please and the short I know it is
plz nowadays plz says it it you're
dropping the vowels near from they are
just keeping the consonants this is an
embedded quality of Arabic language more
like bed yeah yeah absolutely midi yeah
yeah exactly there are many examples of
that so yeah there they would understand
what this is absolutely so the Quran the
first rare form of it was written like
that without vowels yes and even without
dots I will elaborate on this later so
the writing process was going on and on
and from time to time Gabriel would come
and review with the prophets of allah
allah salam the amount of the Quran that
had been revealed during this period of
time whether it's six months or one year
Right the Gabriel would review with the
prophet salallahu slm his memorization
to check that everything is great and to
tell us also another message that we
need to review this from time to time
you can memorize the whole Quran but
after some time we forget so you need
all the time to review and review so now
this is this now the Quran is written
how was it written it was written on
pieces of the leather leather of animal
it was written on some bones of animals
like the shoulder because its spectrum
and you can see many examples in the
book islamic books of these and also it
was written on some pieces of wood
whatever material that they could write
on it yes they wrote on it
and of course this was saved in the
house of the Prophet particularly in the
house of Aisha the last life of the
Prophet sallallahu was the youngest wife
of the prophet salallahu isn't this was
kept there you can imagine here after
year year after year it's growing and
two very big what was going on outside
the house this was going on inside the
house of the Prophet Anya outside of the
Prophet sallallahu sellin everyone would
hear some verses would memorize it and
would teach it to his family members or
to his friends and the prophets allah
salaam himself used to encourage muslims
to learn the Quran he said that the best
amongst you is the one who learns the
Quran who memorizes the Quran and he
teaches it to others so was always in
the hands of the people salute as soon
as it came down it is being taught so
yeah absolutely so people would teach it
to each other do memorize it because
what the reason is they need it in their
prayer because in our prayer when we
pray our daily prayer five daily prayers
we need to recite something from the
continent so they need some material
some stuff to recite while they are
doing they're performing their prayer so
this process was going on and on and on
and some people some of the Companions
outside the house of the prophets allah
allah allah also used to write the quran
they memorize it and those of them that
who were not illiterate who could read
and write so they used to write people
are excited to just write exhalation
something coming from Almighty Allah
there this was going on outside outside
the house of the prototype probably
right now someone's listening to you
wraps no saffron tomato yeah that's what
maybe lectures people say that take note
said they were taken out yeah the people
who were educated who could drive could
write and the people who didn't the u.s.
to memorize and this after 23 years the
quran was completed and it was in the
house of the prophet salallahu Scylla
and for Virgin of that of the quran was
written and the prophets allah salem
reviewed all of them you said virgin
just to a library is that someone might
think also you got through
for different variant no it's the one
that i wrote the one that was written by
a leblabbiy trollop and the one that was
written by obey my cap and the one was
written by z the massager the same quran
the same teacher than the same place and
all of them kept together mm-hmm in the
house of the prophets allah salah this
was the case when the house of the
professor the approximate number of the
people who memorized the Quran at the
time of the Prophet salah salem when he
died the approximate number figure was
200 memorizers and few others this was
the known one because some people who
may i tabbed memorized the Quran outside
but we didn't know them the history did
not record but but even those names the
200 names can be mentioned to you yes
when you dig in who the history of Islam
and you find the authentic books of
Islam you will find the names of all
those ones who memorized the Quran can
show 200 memorizers and 4 cup is written
and kept in the house of the prophets
allah salam richard on leather written
on bones written on pieces of wood and
written where kept in the house of the
Prophet special particularly in the room
or in the house of aisha al gala ha the
main thing now it's being it's memorize
and memorize by hemorrhage now we're
having the written form put down so in
two ways now memorized yes by route
memory by heart and at the same time
it's written on paper written on
documents written on leather and other
things that we're used at that time
we're going to have to cut to a break
and we're going to continue on here on
the Dean show talking about the verbatim
word of God the Quran how it was
compiled here with dr. mahamadu we'll be
right back here in a TV show I came from
a science major when you look at the
Bible says the the earth has four
corners is this wrong
if any Christian and point out a single
unaccomplished is a single unambiguous
treatment where Jesus Christ peace be
upon him says say that I am God or ye
worship me I'm redress of Christianity
welcome back to the Dean show we are
here talking about the compilation of
the verbatim word of god almighty and
arabic we say Allah here with dr. Mann
do please continue on telling us okay
this now here is the situation I'd like
to review it with everybody so everybody
would be sure of what was going exactly
but let me tell you that thing that
right of every Muslim would say that we
know that the four people who were
writing de Laura by name and by history
and biography you would find in any
relation that they were five people or
six people every Muslim knows that they
were four people I mentioned their name
many time and here is the situation the
Quran came from Almighty Allah excuse me
from the preserver tablet to the lowest
heaven in beta Liza as a whole and then
it was in installments according to the
events and the incidents that took place
at the time of the prophets of Allah
reseller and let me elaborate and things
that some of the verses of the Quran
we're not just addressing what happens
in the house of the profits of asylum
what happens in Medina and what happens
in Mecca it was addressing something
global even something for example some
battles between the Romans and the
Persian the Quran addressed them the
Quran was addressing a lot of things not
only the things that we're happening in
the place of the prophet salallahu said
mins ago is it true if I can interject
that there was also the creator
correcting the Prophet peace be upon him
in the Quran well they wear the craters
correcting the Prophet peace be upon him
he would say something and say like when
all turned around he was disciplined
disciplining him yeah he was teaching
him the good morals all these for
example even the Quran itself if the
Prophet SAW a seller
we do an act that does not be faked yeah
means the status a las 10 Tyler would
correct it for example if he ignored
somebody I lost planet I'll i would send
him a verse telling him to do this in de
and if he does anything that it does not
befit him for example a very famous
story and this is very interesting for
people to know what the context of the
word insha allah you find a lot of
muslims who almost every muslim uses
this word in every day perhaps 20 or 30
times in charlotte which means God God
willing God willing yeah it happened
that the Prophet sallallahu assailant
was every time when the people would
come to him the Jews and Christians and
Muslims would ask him questions and the
prophets allah allah allah if he knew he
would answer that if he doesn't know he
would say i don't know so in one case
the Companions used one person came to
him and asked him a question and the
prophets allah salam tell told him that
i'm going to tell you tomorrow
forgetting using the word inshallah God
willing so what happened is that a la
spada wattala to teach him and listen
that he should all the time use
inshallah so he kept the revelation he
did not send gibreel [ __ ] and waited
one day two days and one week after two
weeks and after a long time Gabriel came
to him and taught him this inshallah to
say cool in Chelm this is in the quran
it is in the audience or ok so if he's
writing and now he's correcting him so
does it doesn't no access at all so so
here o mighty a lot of the Creator is
correcting and teaching the prophet
muhammad sallallahu ala what to say in
his things and this is documented in the
quran that the prophets allah salam
didn't do this they didn't say insha
allah and allah is teaching em
disciplining him and discipling every
muslim yeah you because there is nothing
that happens without the will of
almighty allah salam it's a very
important listen that's why you find all
Muslims are using this now to say that
in
allah inshallah so this is a brief
scenario of what was happening two
hundred people memorizing the Quran and
for writers wrote for copies copies i
would say copies of the Quran each one
of them was differ with his own
handwriting and all these were reviewed
whether the memorizer of the Quran the
prophets allah salam used to review
their recitation and to correct it and
at the same time the prophets allah la a
salem used to review what they
companions the fort companies or the for
scribes wrote and he would ask them to
review for each other and he would
recite and each one of them would review
what the other had written and this was
guaranteed this was at the time of the
Prophet salah salem for copies of the
Koran and at least 200 memorizes of the
karate all around Mecca and Medina this
was the situation until the prophets of
allah salam died and these four copies
were left in the house of aisha out of
the law on her and still the number of
the memorizer increases days after days
until the time of abu bakr siddiq of a
worker so did the first caliph came and
I hope in the next episode I will go on
to continue explaining this in very
simple language so everybody would
understand exactly how the Quran was
preserved God willing and that means I
mean what you just said that inshallah
we're going to do part two in cello it
or not that too absolutely where note
thank you very much for thing so we look
for for part two and we hope that God
willing you're going to come back
remember dr. Mohamed Madhu is going to
have his own section at the Dean show
com so you can click you can read his
biography and all the shows that were
doing with him so this is part one
inshallah God willing we're going to be
doing part tune soon so tune in next
week or go online to see this exciting
episode of the car and the verbatim word
of God until next time peace be unto you
miss my life hamdulillah assalamu
alaikum peace be unto you in the studio
dr. mahamadu former professor from the
johns hopkins university we are covering
the compilation of the verbatim word of
not mohammad of not a man but the
verbatim word of god almighty in Arabic
we say Allah this is part 2 you can go
to the Dean show com if you didn't see
part 1 dr. madhu has his own section
there you can watch part 1 we are
continuing talking with the shake and we
left off at the time when the Prophet
peace be upon him had passed and now
we're going to continue from here talk
to a shake so I'm like all equal salon
thank you for being with us here yet
inviting me for talking about the
verbatim word of God and we said it
didn't fall from the sky was in reeled
over 23 years and we came all the way to
the point where the recap talked to us
recap a little bit from episode 1 and
we'll go from there yes we said that at
the death of the Prophet salah salem
this was the situation at least there
were 200 people 200 companions men and
women they memorized the Quran by heart
and they used to use it in every day in
their prayers at the same time there
were four copies written copies by four
well-known companions and this process
took place in the house of the Prophet
peace be upon him they were as we
mentioned as a double health and aaliyah
play with a lip and variably cab and I
creamer a blabby Sofia there's four
people whenever the prophets allah salam
used to get a revelation from a las
panatela via gibril peace be upon it
what happened is that the Prophet
wassallam would call those people and
would ask them to write what was
revealed to prophet muhammad's
Mozilla and we said that a las 10 de la
guaranteed that whatever muhammed
sallalahu salem said in the Quran yet it
was guaranteed one hundred percent that
there is no mistake in it so this was
the situation until the Prophet Sawa's
Anna died so in other words there was
not there was no one compilation of the
whole Quran in a form of a book it was
four copies as I said that looked
written on litters of animal written on
pieces of wood and by the way there are
some of these up till now they are
living and perhaps you can see this in
the screen yeah some examples of the
written on wood some examples of what
we're seeing right now that we were
seeing right now yeah so you can see
this by yourself so the combat Quran was
not compiled in one book but as I said
that four versions of the same thing
written by four different people and
reviewed by the prophet salallahu self
and even the prophets allah allah allah
gibril peace be upon him reviewed the
quran with him twice in the last year
before the prophet sallal I said I'm
done and even some of the Companions
when they knew that gibril reviewed the
Quran 2 times which is not the custom of
gibril because he used to review the
Quran with Muhammad once a year but in
the last so the Companions understood
that mohamed salah salem is going to die
because of this revision that was made
by gibril in the last year of the life
of the prophet saws when abu bakr siddiq
the first caliph came after her just few
weeks they some of the people refuse to
pay zakat to pay the charity that they
used to pay that's one of the pillars of
Islam oh yes absolutely and what
happened is that this led those there
are baba khan subject they say that i'm
going to launch a war against those here
I stem first he meant many negotiations
with them that they insisted on their
understanding so there was a fight which
is very famous fight in the history of
Islam is called the Battle of your llama
yeah during these this battle
approximately around 70 memorizers
passed away died it was a very big
problem yes although they had at that
time more than 200 people but 70 is a
big loss so he was the situation abu
bakr siddiq was sitting and almond hot
tub was sitting and many companions were
sitting and the news came that 70
memorizer died in the battle of Yama it
was a very tragic situation and then
home are we hot tub peace be upon him
the second caliph came up with this idea
he said that hey aboubakar why shouldn't
we compile the Quran in one book in one
most of the word must have in Arabic
language which is what does that mean
driving us literally speaking most of
means the place of pages or the place of
paper in other words a book yeah so the
Quran was not compiled into one thing at
that time so how much will have Bob
suggested this to above a christening
the natural response of the Caliph he
rejected the idea and how I'm gonna be
hot pop started talking to him asking
him why I'm over custody or reject this
idea why do you reject this idea he said
simply I cannot do anything that the
Prophet peace be upon him they didn't do
see how how those people were so smart
they were afraid to do anything that may
take them out of the way of the Prophet
said no he said no he refused then the
Omaha top started explaining the concept
too many companions they were convinced
and then when almost all the companions
there was a consensus among the
Companions of the Prophet sallallahu
seller agreed on this issue that it
should be compiled in one at that time
then and only then abu bakr siddiq the
Caliph accepted that and by the way here
is then one thing in Islam if the
compounds if there is a consensus among
the companions to do something it
becomes part of the religion so
companions these were when you we say
his friends people that were living
there living at the time so I have a
problem they knew has live in event bay
or know where everything we're recording
everything even if the prophets allah
salam would unbutton his shirt they
would unbutton their chair they just
want to imitate the prophets allah salah
even if sitting putting one leg on
another link they would do the same
thing even if he's using his right hand
like this they would use the
right-hander with imitating emulating
the prophets allah allah in everything
that he did even in things that they
were not related to the religion and now
not making this into one compile book
during the life of the project upon him
was it because he was living at the time
he was living with no only that there
were four copies yeah and now the matter
is left in the hands of the people okay
so this was their idea now what happened
is that abu bakr siddiq called zeinab
lahars remember when i talk daily
perhaps one of the four people who the
scribes who used to read the Quran at
the time of the prom yeah so he asked
him to do that you know that he's the
leader of the nation asking one of the
people in the nation and he refused he
said I'm sorry I cannot do that yeah the
reason is that this was not done at the
time of the Prophet selasa see how
cautious the companions were they just
wanted to stick to the way of the
prophets
Lonnie wasilla and what happened after
that when all the companions explained
this to him that there is a consensus
and he said that well la he had they
asked me to remove the mountain of org
this is the very famous mountain and
close to Medina have they asked me of
the Companions asked me to remove the
mountain of a hood from its place to
another place it would have been an
easier task for me than to do this
compliation hold it right there we got
to take a break don't use your play
shake we'll be right back on the game
show all of the profits would have been
labeled Muslims because this essential
message was the same in essence
submissions
this is God talking to you how can I
stand behind the pulp and Sunday morning
and preach a sermon that I knew was at
variance with the actual taproot of
Christianity we're back here on the Dean
show with dr. Mohammed man do it would
have been easier you said to move the
mountain of a hood of then to compile
the Quran to do an act that that was not
done at the Prophet salah salem and this
still does how smart the Companions of
the prophets were also aware how smart
with the disciples of the profits of
allies anywhere they wanted to keep
everything as it was in the time of the
Prophet solid ice but there was a need
that to compile it in one book and what
happened at that time when he started
compiling it the way I'd like to
elaborate in this now we have four
copies as we said four different
handwritings because each one companion
has his own different font or different
handwriting my handwriting is different
from your handwriting from your
handwriting each one has his unique same
Cartwright nothing different there of
course you say we're still the four
versions there so what happened is that
he started licking yes the good version
that was not affected by the element of
time you know that by the element of
time sometimes there was wearing out
sometimes the leakage of the ink
sometimes there are many other factors
that affect the time after 23 years now
it's we were talking about 24 years so
there so he started selecting for
example the first page you would take it
from the copy of Zade and the second
page would be taken from the copy of a
variably cap and from these four copies
he compiled one virgin and they compiled
it together and it came in a form of a
book absolutely it was not like that
simply because it was not written on
paper it was written as we said leather
and so you can imagine how he
would that book and I'm quite sure that
it may extend from this world to this
one but they were compiled together and
what happened after that so all the lift
papers from the four copies they were
gathered together and they were born
burnt hey was burnin so let's just make
this clear you're saying that during the
time of the Prophet peace be upon these
were they were short comes were the
copies that were made with the treat the
chief scribe who was there at the time
now again he's there again the same will
check evade it and these for their
brought together they're not different
versions like that is another there's no
writing Everest compliation believe I
together in one book yeah you can
imagine that this book and this is the
wisdom of the crater that have got earth
making all these steps have with the
consensus of the old well the consensus
there's no fight disputing like a they
shouldn't be here what are you doing
there's no fire sonnet they all agree a
lot of discussion very academic and
scientific and deep discussion allowing
them to see the rushes they're all
god-fearing people absolutely they're
not trying to make a mistake here
absolutely yeah there's no not a single
person one percent an error here error
factor so the Quran was compiled in the
house of Abu Bakr Siddiq and was left of
course and this was the house of eyeshot
of the alarm now you said Bernie because
there are a lot of people here who may
be just out of ignorance absolute or
intentionally unintentionally as they
say that look they were different
versions okay this is because now can
they burn verse or ants I'm not great on
this this is very good question first of
all how can they should be four
different versions if they are reviewed
by the Prophet a lhasa see there were
these four copies were written at the
time of the prophet and he used to
review them from time to time yeah and
he used to ask each one of those
describes to review the other copy that
was written so all of them as the group
of four people they are responsible for
these four copies yeah and this London
led the wisdom of muhammad sallallahu
selling it might have been an
inspiration to him by Allah but this is
the wisdom he made for people not just
one copy or two copies why because the
effect of time might have made some
changes when you write a paper and you
leave it for some time yeah when you
come after some years ago you see the
effect of the time on it yeah absolutely
so the profs Alison was so wise so there
now four copies from these four copies
only one copy was made and was connected
together compiled together to make the
first must have and this must have which
means book yes this must have was known
to be called the most half of a B
baccarat what stuff oven the reason is
it was made at the time of every book
and you will see later on when we talk
when explain this at the time of us man
yeah it was called Osman because it was
then at the time of hustling it was not
written by osmond it was not written by
abu bakr so didn't even know what was
the Duke himself was not one of the
writers are on yeah yes so now we're at
the time of abu bakr a low income of a
public lucidus who lived almost 42 years
and then he died and after the time of
abu bakr so deep came the second health
this was a situation there is only one
copy and there are many memorizers of
the Quran every day passes a lot of
people and whereas the Quran why because
they need it in their daily prayers they
use it five times a day then and some of
them were a man's leading the prayers so
they needed it and continuously whenever
somebody makes a mistake he will be
corrected by the followers who pray
behind them and this is again one of the
wisdoms of the congregational prayer of
the Muslims and that's why we are all
encouraged as Muslims to pray in
congregation and to see that if an
amount makes a mistake everyone who is
the follower of him will correct him
during the prayer yeah so now we have
Abu Bakr so did and it's compiled there
but he passes away they passed away when
a situation was now this book it was
there abu bakr siddiq came home of the
hot dog came after that what happened is
that the book was moved from the house
of Aisha to the
of Huff's these are the prior game they
say why cause it's why yes they're still
alive I still alive yeah yeah what
happened is that at the time of horrible
hot tub Rhoda lon I don't want to go
into details but anyway nothing happened
Omar my hot tub used to send people
especially the memorizers to the new
countries that became Islamic countries
because the Muslims opened many
countries and Islam spread in many
countries so how modern kitab used to
send some memorizers to teach people the
new converse or the new reverts to Islam
this this the Quran so for on now is
going beyond that can be on Medina to
the new lands that had been added to the
Islamic countries so this was the
situation at the time of Hamid
innumerable hot tub passed away nothing
happened still have there's one more
stuff most hostile at the Prophet
exactly what has my eyes russia house
still there still same one that compiled
during the abu bakr siddiq okay exactly
the same one that was taken from the
fort cop is that one how many years
later is this now now you're talking
about Homer of the hot tub lived
approximately 12 years so 12 and 2 1200
40 years still the same copy and what
happens now that is the Islamic nation
is increasing is expanding in every
direction now all the memorizer used to
spread out and to teach other people how
to memorize the Quran so the number of
the memorizers is increasing day after
date men and women old and young every
Arabs and non-arabs yeah at the time of
ours man the third caliph there was a
big expansion so what happened in that
when the people recite the Quran when I
recite the Quran especially as let me go
back to the time of the Prophet
sallallahu ala the people who memorized
the Quran were from different tribes and
these tribes of course they have their
own dialect for example you can see that
in English
the difference between the New York
dialect and I got a new york dialect and
the texas dialect chicago people and
their places they have different like
they read the same word but with the
dialect yeah yeah with an accent or a
dialect and this is exactly what was
happening in the time of the tribes were
spreading here and there with long
distance between them is not close
communication there was no media and
then so the prophet salla solemn did not
change their dialect but they used to
pronounce their the words according to
their dialing for example let me tell
you some people would say schedule and
some people would say shitty oh yeah and
this is something common in every
language so and the prophets allah
silent endorsed these right and of
course he accepted these pronunciation
give us one more like that what you said
you said schedule + schedule schedule +
schedule and it won't be another example
so we can hit hit home with the same the
same work mother or our mom mom mom or
mama or something like yes so ppl is
every man's which this is just what it
is absolute I it's a way of pronouncing
it yeah that's it I don't see the word
yes that's it and there are many
examples in many languages near that so
now those people when they spread over
the world teaching the people so if i
say that i pronounce it this way and you
pronounce it this way so they needed to
match this with a written copy oh now
it's coming home to a judgment ok so now
ok we need a written copy so this there
was a need at the time of us land for
hurling common mm-hmm so what happened
is that just you try to imagine can you
take out this and make a copy from the
bone or from now of course it was
impossible yeah so what happened is he
brought zaid him the highest in the
first one again he's still alive it was
still he still there is still change
this is the wisdom of a las problem and
he brought other companions with him to
help him
and he wrote one copy by his hand
writing he copied from those this most
half of a be back he wrote it by hand
now you can imagine that on paper and it
shrank down to this side and perhaps the
video which show the people that's this
an example of a huge it was so huge what
all of it on paper and they made with
the collaboration of three other
companions he made seven copies so now
there are seven copies take written by
the same person where copied from there
was this compilation of the Quran and
these seven copies were sent to seven
places one Mecca one Medina one al
bathra 1l qufu one bahrain 12 Yemen and
one to a chef syria and lebanon seven
copies were centered and by the way some
of these copies until now there exists
one of them is in Turkey and one of the
museum's there one of them is in Egypt
the sum of these original I'm talking
about these seven copies that were
written almost 1300 years ago or 1400
years ago they are still there and in
addition to as a number of the memorizer
that is increasing not only among the
Arabs among all the other countries this
was the situation at the time of Osman
and that's why this virgin that we have
nowadays it's called as Manning because
this was just done during as this was
done at the time nothing different from
what absolutely i'm absolutely office
time absolutely even if it was still
without vowels without dots it was in
the same for my but seven copies of it
and the memorizers of the Koran used to
take it as a reference if they're a
mistake in the rumor ization happens we
said that in the time of the third
caliph as mad enough on the situation
was like this there were seven copies
handwritten
by the same chief scribe whose name is
Zeta Mahara and these copies were sent
to these countries when as mentioned
these seven places one of them to Yemen
one of them is to sham Syrian Lebanon
and another one was sent to becerra
another one was sent to kufa one was
sent to Bahrain and to remain in the
area one in Mecca and the other one was
in Medina seven copies written by the
same person they were done at the time
of our smell and that's why they are
called Osmani right and that's why many
of the virgins of the Quran that we have
nowadays they call it worth manic most
of referring to that they were done at
the time of our Samantha third cat
library when you say because when we we
know we have multiple versions of the
Bible when you say version because
people think now this is a different
course and there's something to take it
okay this one what do you mean yeah it
is said that seven copies were made so
it's the from it's the same by the same
person you copied from each one of them
he is the same person yeah who did the
same thing so that's why I'm saying that
so the seven of them they were spread
here and there now we call this I don't
know what we call it virgin or addiction
or yeah yeah but we call it as many
because the font here this was the same
font that was taken from the time that
the Quran was copied at the time of
arslan that's why they call it as Manny
god talk to us now about you continue on
but just a side note when was it during
this time that the Quran some of the
people that were making short hand they
were taking notes that it was taken so
there would be confusion and they would
earned absolutely yeah the time of us
man he recommended that you know that
there are many Muslims everywhere in the
world especially in the Arabia yet they
were writing for their own they memorize
the Quran they want to write so some of
them might have written yes the whole
brand some of them might have written
part of it so at the time of ours man
when these copies were made they asked
all the people who have some part of the
on or even other copies of the Quran
they would be collected and burned
that's it this is a necessary that was
there much resistance from the people uh
no no of course they could know that
this is this isn't like a you know by
force like knocking on door breaking or
is this taking this notice this is what
other dude because that the companions
were on the same level of our landlord
alarm and some of them where yes even
had greater impact and Islam and even in
understanding the Quran then then ours
man have not found on the lawn so anyway
the all these pieces and parts were
gathered together and when burned it and
we still have the seven copies and when
as I said this you can imagine the long
distance between these places that the
Quran were sent to the time of ali bin
ABI talib the fourth caliph nothing
happened there is no change and this
continued on and on at the time of abdul
malik at number one the concept of
dotting putting the dots on the day with
this was not there and and and that's
why you would find that some words yes
needed to have yes in the alphabet this
is changed in the writing system of the
early so the added the dots to
differentiate between what was this now
this was at the time of abdul malik a
bloomer one how FAR's is after my say
not after us man after alabama talib
this would be immediately of the just
few years after years yeah just a few
years and this was for the purpose of
what for the purpose of us said this is
a change in the writing system mm-hmm
yes nothing change was done by
absolutely it's the writing system for
example i will tell people now look at
the word color in the british writing
and the word color is written in the
American writing you would see that this
you is written and in the American
system they drop the you right look at
the word night n IG HT and now they
people write it in I te right yeah so
it's still the same pronunciation the
same word at the same meaning does not
change anything but it is the change
in the writing system and this happens
in all the world right so this the
dotting system was introduced at the
time of up the medical marijuana and
this was a per-mile by a person called i
will as well dually we know the person
by name and we know that this was well
documented there is nothing to do to
hide or to conceal here and at the same
time the Quran was continuing to be
memorized more and more and more people
now are writing copies different copies
from the seven copies that were rushed
me you love it or you get a copy and you
try to make a copy of the original one
until printing was introduced and
hundreds and thousands and millions of
copies were made at the same time the
number of memorizers is increasing until
recently in the last few years in the
20th century there was a statistic about
the memorizes of the Quran they are
approximately nine point three million
memorizers of the Quran d cover it from
cover to cover they memorize it heart by
heart from cover to cover and they are
almost everywhere in the world and fifty
percent of them at least in the
subcontinent of India and Pakistan and
advanced let's leave off there and I
think that this opens up if you're
willing to come back god woman where we
can talk about more about the Quran and
this was just how was compiled but you
know many of the different solutions to
a lot of the problems we're having here
it being a guidance for the man
absolutely describing who our Creator is
who he is and the wonderful wards our
paradise and all the beautiful things
that if a person lives how the crater
wants them to live all the delights and
the beautiful things about seeing their
Lord in Paradise and Michaella all these
wonderful things that we can talk about
scientific miracles but you just go on
and on sayshell a lot next up is so part
3 absolutely ok and that's it we're here
with dr. mundo he agreed so if he agreed
i'm sure now he's going to find a time
you could find a time and come back here
here at the Dean show again dr. mundo he
has his own section of the Dean show
comm check it out to see one parts one
to this one if you didn't see all of it
and then inshallah God willing
we're going to continue on talking about
the verbatim word of God the Quran see
you next time so not like them I come
from a science major when you look at
the Bible says the earth has four
corners the is this wrong if any
Christian can point out a single
unaccomplished is a single unambiguous
treatment where Jesus Christ peace be
upon him says say that I am God always
worshipped me am British oppression it
it's called it lay everybody sleeping I
arise and ask a lot of thinking me Omar
you see all are you know